[Musique]
bon je vois rien vous êtes bonsoir chers
amis c'est un grande joie d'être ce soir
ici pour vous parler d'une passion qui
me tient depuis de très nombreuses
années et je vois d'ailleurs d'autant
plus grande que je me trouve ici devant
vous par un double hasard je suis
d'origine libanaise et je suis j'ai
quitté un pays en guerre je suis arrivé
ici comme comme réfugiés alors que la
suisse n'était pas du tout notre pays de
destination c'est une très longue
histoire
et puis hazard aussi parce que je viens
vous parler de musique d'une certaine
musique absolument fascinante vous allez
voir alors que moi j'ai été avocat au
barreau de genève avant d'aller étudier
à paris à la sorbonne la philosophie
mais c'est vrai que depuis que j'ai
quitté mon pays je garde une certaine
nostalgie de lorient ça me quitte pas et
puis plus particulièrement il nous
certaine nostalgie d'une esthétique
orientale et plus particulièrement d'une
esthétique musicale une certaine musique
pas la musique populaire pas la musique
folklorique arabe mais une musique dite
classique musiques savantes ou encore
musique d'art une musique qui dans
certaines périodes de son histoire a eu
des princes et des rois pour pour
mécènes et alors comme tout tout tout
passion on a envie de la partager avec
les gens qu'on aime et puis alors à
chaque fois que je voulais en parler
avec mes amis ne comprenait pas du tout
vous allez voir c'est très dur une
déroute en ça semble pas être de la
musique
il me disais mais qu'est ce que c'est et
puis ça semble en savoir de niche comme
ça enfin parce que je rentrais dans la
théorie de ces choses et puis et puis me
disait écoute plutôt bach ou mozart
c'est ça c'est ça c'est beau ça c'est la
perfection quoi alors être chez vous je
vous fait écouter maintenant ce que je
fais écouter à mes amis en espérant que
vous partiez pas en courant un alors de
son est bon faut que ça pète
[Musique]
ouais
m
et
[Musique]
bon alors c'est quasiment mission
impossible pour moi ce soir mais je
voudrais à la fin mon objectif c'est de
vous dire qu'il ya de bonnes raisons
pour aimer cette musique
moi elle me passionne et bien
figurez-vous que par exemple le monsieur
là avec ta grosse grosse moustache au
milieu c'est lui qui chante était adulé
au caire la deuxième moitié du xixème
siècle et est même surnommé le caruso
enrico caruso de lorient c'est le
chanteur ténor italien pardon du sud de
l'italie caluso de lorient enfin c'est
dire son importance aujourd'hui il est
quasiment oublié bon et puis alors je me
suis dit que face à cette
incompréhension que vous partagez
certainement ce soir je me suis dit pour
bien en parler je devais moi même
parfaitement bien la comprendre alors
j'ai voyagé j'ai beaucoup voyagé je suis
allé en orient au caire j'ai passé des
jeux des mois mémorable enfin je
n'oublierai jamais en train de de
m'exercer à cet instrument la technique
de cet instrument le oud dans une
vieille bâtisse du xviiie siècle dont le
vieux caire enfin c'était magnifique
et puis istanbul aussi je suis allé
rencontrer des musiciens des grands
maîtres de la musique ottomane et la
musique soufie turc et puis et puis à
beyrouth à l'université antonine où
j'allais parler avec des chercheurs qui
travaillent à renouveler la théorie de
cette musique et puis et puis da mince
et puis à alep damas je n'oublierai
jamais là cet appel à la prière pendant
que je méditais devant le tombeau de
saint jean baptiste
il est enterré a enfin cédé voyage où
j'ai voulu vraiment sur le terrain
sentir comment percevez cette musique
et puis j'ai ouvert les livres aussi je
me suis plongé dans la littérature et là
je croyais avoir à faire en fait un
savoir denis chien c'est ce que
probablement vous pensez à un intérêt
très particulier en fait non ça m'a
ouvert des champs de savoir immense et
qui pose des questions vraiment crucial
déjà en histoire quelles sont les
civilisations qui ont porté cette
musique comment elle s'est développée à
travers les lieux les agents absolument
fascinant et puis quelles sont les
caractéristiques fondamentales en
théorie dans cette musique qui qui la
rendent si étrange à notre oreille ici
et puis des questions alors ça pour moi
qui étudie la philosophie ce qui me
passionnait le plus est plus particulier
en ce solo j en anthropologique comment
va-t-on vers une culture qu'on considère
comme tout à fait autre si différente si
perturbante que parfois elle nous
effraie on a envie de dial et seulement
avec nos concepts est ce qu'on y va
vraiment avec nos concepts ou est ce
qu'on essaie de faire cet effort
d'empathie et prendre un peu les
représentations l'eau
dans le revêtement des questions immense
en philosophie et puis alors dans mes
lectures et bien je suis tombé c'était
c'est pas un de mes amis qui dit ça mais
c'est un très grand compositeur français
et critique musical français il est mort
en 1869 essayer de deviner qui c'est qui
a pu dire les orientaux appel musique ce
que nous nommons charivari donc c'est du
n'importe quoi du bruit comme ce que je
vous ai fait entendre hélas cette
personne a probablement entendu une
musique très similaire à celle que
écouter et pour l horrible et le goût
alors quelqu'un deviner 1869 la
symphonie symphonie fantastique des
troyens bon c'est bien c'est berlioz
quelqu'un a dit dans la salle quand même
on est 180 ce soir voilà effectivement
cessé berlioz alors on fait quoi avec ce
jugement alors bon moi je suis passionné
par cette musique mais qui a envie de
comprendre
ben j'ai voulu le prendre au sérieux et
puis et j'aimerais avec vous ce soir
essayer de voir si à travers l'histoire
comme j'ai dit à travers la théorie de
cette musique à travers aussi des des
réflexions d'ordre sociologique
anthropologique est ce que ce jugement
est fondée ou est ce que c'est comme il
arrive même au génie à ce que ce
jugement est plutôt at il faut peut-être
même c'est une bêtise que ce berlioz
notre ami berlioz raconte alors voilà
déjà un peut-on parler comme le fait
berlioz des orientaux un terme qui met
tous les orientaux dans le même panier
et là je disais histoire leur très
rapidement l'histoire vous savez les
arabes sont partis de la halle à médine
la mecque la région ouest de l'arabie
saoudite qu'on appelle le free jazz est
très très vite sont montés vers damas et
on sait déjà c'est attester que ces gens
avaient un goût très marqué pour la
poésie et la poésie déclamée on est dans
une tradition orale qui dit poésie
déclamée et orale dit déjà une forme de
musicalité parole langue arabe et
musique sont intimement liés il arrive à
damas et la caisse qu'ils rencontrent et
bien des gens comme moi c'est à dire des
chrétiens de culture grecque et qui
chante le chant byzantin encore
aujourd'hui dans notre culture liban on
chante tantôt en grec sur des sur des
mélodies arabes d'antan en arabe sur des
sur des mélodies grec enfin vous voyez
que les choses sont mélangés et déjà là
y'a de quoi remettre en cause ce vocable
de orientaux puisqu'il ne couvre il
couvre une variété sur le terrain
très diversifiés bigarrée multicolores
vous voyez et puis alors ensuite le
foyer de la civilisation 751 ils se
déplacent vers vers l'est et là c'est la
grande civilisation des arabes
l'époque des abbassides qui a pour
centre bagdad bagdad qui a un jet de
pierre de l'ancienne capitale des perses
de l'ancienne capitale des sassanides
des perses thesis on la leur capital
était vraiment très proches 30 km au sud
de bagdad et puis là-bas ils rencontrent
les perses justement il est plus grands
théoriciens de cette musique de gros
pavés nous sont restés de cette musique
absolument fascinante et bien ces
auteurs sont de naissance percée mais
ils ont écrit même si l'on écrit en
arabe
je vous ai dit que je suis allé à
l'université antonine à beyrouth qui
travaillent un peu sur ces manuscrits et
ils ont essayé de reproduire sur la base
d'un manuscrit très précis du xiiie
siècle à quoi pouvait ressembler cette
musique dans la cour
c'est d'un raffinement immense quand on
s'y plonge une cour à l'époque
abbassides accord pouvait ressembler
cette musique écoutée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
leur amour
[Musique]
allez
m
[Musique]
vous verrez les caractéristiques de
cette musique principales sont plus ou
moins rester les mêmes et ont traversé
le temps je vais en parler plus tard et
puis revenons un peu à l'histoire après
bagdad fin xiiie siècle les
civilisations s'éparpille un de ces
foyers et le caire mais aussi les en
même temps il ya les turcs à istanbul
qui font de l'embl l'immense empire
ottoman
c'est pas les seuls foyers mais disons
ce d'importance et puis là disons 19e
siècle renaissance des arabes c'était le
caire le sens de l'art le centre de
cette renaissance
beaucoup des changes encore une fois il
n'ya pas de limite homogène n'y a pas de
frontières homogène dans ce monde de la
musique et bien beaucoup d'échangés
entre le caire des musiciens du caire
qui se rendait à la sublime porte et
puis ramené dans leurs bagages et bien
des compositions ottomane envoyer toutes
ces influences vous voyez encore donc
pour répondre à la question il a tort
notre ami berlioz de parler des
orientaux parce que parce que la réalité
est beaucoup plus complexe
et puis alors notre ami berlioz et bien
traite cette musique de charivari ça n'a
pas de sens comme très probablement ça
me ferait plaisir que vous le pensiez
aussi parce que j'aimerais vous faire
aussi changé d'avis en essayant de
comprendre à travers les
caractéristiques de cette histoire de
cette de cette musique caractéristique
fondamentale pourquoi ça sonne si
bizarre à nos oreilles alors rien à deux
des caractéristiques d'abord ça tient à
une note qui n'existe pas sur la le
piano d'un compositeur comme berlioz et
au piano c'est l'instrument de référence
eh bien il ya des notes que dans la
musique arabe on ne trouve pas sur les
touches noires et blanches d'un piano
d'un compositeur comme berlioz et bien
je vais vous jouez cette note
et j'espère que je la jouerai assez bien
pour qu'elles sonnent faux à vos
oreilles mais qu'elle sonne parfaitement
juste aux oreilles d'un libanais ou d'un
syrien qui serait dans la salle alors il
ya majorité enfin il ya principalement
deux grandes couleurs dans la musique
classique européenne une couleurs
joyeuses et puis le conduit mi majeur et
puis triste qu'on dit mineur ça tient
surtout à la troisième notes de la gamme
alors tout le monde est familier de ces
deux gammes ça c'est joyeux
[Musique]
la troisième date est celle ci elle est
joyeuse triste c'est que plutôt comme ça
cette troisième date est mineur dite
mineure jusque là c'est clair et bien
nos amis les arabes ils ont une note
cette troisième note qui n'est ni majeur
ni mineurs elle est dite neutre
elles ressemblent à ceux ci
est ce que vous sentez la différence est
majeure ces mineurs est ce assez neutre
cette note n'existe peut évidemment pas
sur le clavier de piano d'un berlioz
alors qu'elle est prépondérant dans
cette musique quand elle n'est absente
ça va pas on n'aime pas ça moi ça me
fait pas vibrer quand elle n'existe
quant elle n'apparaît pas dans un
morceau déjà la salle berlioz peut-être
ne l'a pas compris cette histoire de
notes elle remonte au moins au viiie
siècle
et puis alors qu'un autre
caractéristique qu'on appelle les
terreaux faut ni pour le comprendre
c'est très simple dans un orchestre
classique européen vous avez des groupes
d'instruments dix ans et puis chaque
groupe d'instruments les violons ont
leur partition je suis allé les flûtes
ont leur partition est puis les
violences elles ont leurs partitions
chaque chacune différente un cd
partitions différentes puis jouer
ensemble elles s'accumulent dans nos
oreilles pour former ce qu'on appelle
des accords ou des harmonies un peu
comme quand on gratte sur une guitare
toutes les cordes en même temps ça fait
un accord ou quand vous presser de vos
doigts
le clavier d'un piano ensemble ça fait
des accords ou des harmonies ça ça
n'existe pas dans cette musique non tout
le monde a exactement la même partition
on joue qu'une seule mélodie il n'y a
pas de notes qui se superposent tout le
monde joue exactement le même lundi mais
là attention on n'ajoute pas banalement
comme ça tous à l'unisson non chacun
chaque instrumentiste il y met du sien
et selon lui ses propres goûts et les
possibilités sont un instrument y met
des fioritures des ornementations et là
je veux c'est choisir un exemple extrême
où c'est une même mélodie
moi je la reconnais pas ce que c'est un
morceau fameux mais vous allez voir lé
il a tellement de fioritures chaque
instrumentiste il met tellement du sien
qu'on a peine à ponlat perçoit à peine
cette mélodie alors à écouter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monde
ça c'est génial faut que ça fonctionne
comme ça sinon on s'ennuie pas ce que
l'oreille à elle elle s'attarde à
at-elle fioritures du violoncelle furet
dur du oud enfin c'est juste génial
bon mais finalement cher ami ça va
cesser du charivari non je vous
comprenez et puis la dernière c'est avec
ça que je veux terminer c'est cette
réflexion je vous ai dit un d'ordre
sociologique anthropologique
je crois que le jugement de berlioz est
symptomatique d'un certain discours qui
a une très longue histoire et qui a fait
l'objet d'un livre devenir un grand
classique dans les facultés de
sociologie et d'anthropologie
l'orientalisme d'edward said
le palestinien professeur de littérature
comparée et il montre combien l'histoire
de ce discours à travers les âges
surtout au 19ème siècle était avant tout
le discours des deux superpuissances de
l'époque les anglais et les français un
discours porté sur une certaines régions
du monde qu'on appelle lorient beaucoup
trop grande et un discours trop
globalisant essentialisant figeant les
gens les arabes sont lorient c'est alors
que j'ai essayé ce soir de vous montrer
que les choses vues de l'intérieur
lorsqu'on fait l'effort d'aller sur le
terrain vrai anthropologue il va passer
dix ans sur le terrain c'est comme ça
qu'il fait son bon boulot ce n'est pas
de l'extérieur qui vient mais le
problème avec ce discours c'est qu'il
vient de l'extérieur en surprenant
lui-même pour modèle c'est comme si
berlioz venait nous expliquer aux
orientaux ce que cette musique peut-être
sur son piano
or elle est injouable elle ne peut pas
la jouer sur un piano voiliers et 10 etc
pour t on je comprends à le jugement de
berlioz parce que n'étant pas jouable
lui n'ayant que comme unique référence
son piano et bien il ne pouvait que
juger cette musique comme étant du bruit
et que les les orientaux m l'horrible
alors que pour moi ça me donne beaucoup
d'émotion et puis alors j'ai rajouté un
slide il ya deux jours parce que je
relisais la la correspondance de
flaubert qui lui aussi est tombé dans le
biais de l'orientalisme mais il a cette
phrase il dit un de ses amis en passant
en plus c'est assez
génie de ce bonhomme pour qu'une chose
soit intéressante
il suffit de la regarder assez longtemps
alors j'espère ce soir vous avoir au
moins donner le goût de ce regard ce
durable de ce regard tenace qui rend les
choses si intéressante voilà j'aimerais
terminer maintenant on joue souvent une
improvisation dans un dans un mc ramin
modes le mode d'affichage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]